My name is Evgenija Stojcevska.
I’m from Skopje, Macedonia.
My name is August,
and I was born in Vietnam.
My name is Audrey,
and my home is Oakland, California.
I’m from Thessaloníki , Greece.
My name is Gaby Ruiz-Colón,
and I’m from Aguadilla, Puerto Rico.
My name is Haley Adams,
and I’m from Bureau County, Illinois.
My name is Herman Bhupal,
and I’m from Chapel Hill, North Carolina.
I’m Josh McTaggart. I’m from England.
[ Man Narrating ] Students from all 50
of the United States and over 100 countries.
I’m just a California girl.
My name is Majahonkhe Shabangu.
All living, learning and growing together
in the one place they all call home.
I’m from Sweden,
but I’m at home at Harvard.
I’m at home at Harvard.
I am from the Kingdom of Swaziland,
but Harvard is my home.